welcome to this video playing crapper
blanca karuppa blank i am one of the fun
handles here and he's super hydrated 25
something let's see what we get I'm
Kings Indian Oh noise playing total
freestyle hey okay yeah maybe prevent g5
for the moment I don't know if I want to
cancel in this position now let's just
put some stuff in the center here 96
okay so how is he going to play here
with short castles probably be five in
this position or not yeah and I always
like to put things in the center maybe
demand maybe he can go t5 them with a
good position hmm yeah that's certainly
true yeah i mean this bill was very
obvious but i could I didn't really I
didn't understand that this is really
good for him especially the control of
you for is very useful ok let's see a 6b
five is the only thing that gives me
some play in this position let's do that
even if it costs a pawn it doesn't
actually take stakes night x there was
an ID be three so i can take now and you
will play before sending me back to be
seven which is an awful square we can
take age six and very stupid here right
why didn't I think about this one I
should I should have thought about this
move
my king position makes them somewhat
weaker and pressure now f4 especially
makes them could be problematic and
Bishop g5 for an awkward pin hmm I don't
like how I played that should have
thought about the age six pawn really ok
at least I can trade some stuff so yeah
maybe this first Bishop g5 I can play
queen bee six maybe yes f4 i am now or
this one okay my night on b7 is really a
sad piece
yeah he's still just a tech before he
has an idea for him we can play 94 maybe
but ok I can oh ok so he wants to
directly attack me them takes takes
Queen g5 as an idea definitely is and I
cannot really take and my queen is
offside yeah Queen a3 was bad yeah let's
let's see if I can I actually maybe this
check and Queen deform this this could
be interesting White Queen d4 takes
takes mmm not it's not great hey it
really isn't great Bishop g4 fatigues
takes Knight takes yeah
now that he can take and still play
Queen g5 that looks really bad mmm-hmm
rook e8 maybe takes rook cheeks what
about if I just give up the pawn down
hmm 24 takes takes 25 I don't know if
that is really so bad if this happens
take stakes Quincy five min c3 is
hanging maybe that's not so bad with
this move now this I did not expect okay
let's just make sure i'm not getting
checkmated even if this position is
worse for me at still seem some better
than what I had before
okay so I this he has root a hmm
cantique I have no square with this tix
chinks
yeah yeah I know it is a bad position I
know Jim might be seven looks really sad
about do that next
really bad what is he thinking about I
can just take g5 that's simple and
probably winning that's not I can do it
it's not not bad or anything I could
have taken g5 immediately I wonder 95
can I go see three or something probably
not i can give me check and knight on c3
let's just just terrible this position
if he takes i might have rook c8 for a
little bit of counter play it's not not
not great or something about okay now at
six I what a disaster sure nothing I can
do
can I come on let's resign that there
was a just and the unjust unfocused game
money so yeah allowing him to take on
age six is just just a bad idea I mean
it didn't do it consciously this is the
bad thing b5 until we canceled so let's
let's think about this for a moment I
really should have thought here a little
bit before I just allow him to take
their what about this and maybe he can
take now yeah it's not not quite clear
what my compensation is ok now he took
their I mean I don't think that this is
so bad it just just not comfortable to
play night on b7 makes a really bad
impression so I went there if form chess
actually right and it takes f is just ok
for black yeah but this is difficult I
mean I didn't really see how this is
good I Queen a one check well this is
what I overlooked Queen a one check very
sloppy calculation yeah that means I'm
definitely okay if he if he cannot take
with the Queen here then I'm okay okay
yeah this was maybe even that I don't
actually think that at the beginning it
was so bad f5 to talk and now g5 maybe
yeah of course I have to take at five
why didn't I take f5 it's much easier
than g5 the big problem is I I need a
tempo I need a tempo to get to a eight
this is the problem I totally
I have what what in New York move and
they played it immediately yeah as usual
the immediate moves are really often
[ __ ] you should think about of
course he wants to play rook a too if i
just take here i have absolutely no
problem I don't see any problem here he
has to recapture furture and now I can
go to a 8 myself and what exactly is
white white advantage here I mean I
don't I don't see it that those those
pawns are also vulnerable ok man I still
have a bad night on Bassam I mean the
engine says equal but i'm not totally
sold on that the night on b7 makes a bad
impression cin king up yeah maybe this
is the point my king can can get active
quickly this is the the engine line
Bishop cheeks okay three and somehow
equal hmm i don't know i mean this is of
course miles better than the game but
yeah now okay to know I'm just lost it's
really just like that he invades were
they on a seven and they don't get my
stuff coordinated yeah g5 was a horrible
that was really bad Naji hive I mean
this is not it wouldn't be so terrible
in case when I get in bouquet eight but
I don't it's just he's just first it was
just the totally totally mindless move
okay well thanks for watching